don't carry it all yourself you need
help everybody every leader needs help
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders how are you i'm
very excited to be here thank you for
having me quite honored
this is a going to be a wonderful
journey that you'll take me through over
these next 20 minutes i'm excited to
hear about
your personal journey i'm here about and
i'm very excited to hear about
the organization that you founded and
you're you know just the the whole
process of both being a tech executive
but also being
but also owning this organization and
being so passionate about empowering
empowering the missions that you're off
to so i don't i i don't want to give too
much away
please take it away girls and powers
tell me about this
oh sure thank you so much again for
having me uh my name is kiwa
aleya i am the ceo and founder of girl
stem stars
we advance girls of color from
underrepresented communities in stem
science technology engineering and math
a lot of people ask me
hmm why did you start girl stem stars
the whole entrepreneurial story
and it's actually very organic um
i started doing this type of work at a
tech company
years ago where i was bringing in girls
of color
every wednesday we had about a busload
of 50 girls that would come in and each
department in the tech company
would teach the girls something and then
we'd bust them back um
from there i noticed that we didn't have
a lot of black girls
we had latina we had pan-asian we had
you know we had a lot of girls
but i maybe had one or two black girls
and so as things happen
i wound up having a
near-death experience and
in 2013 i was supposed to have a routine
surgery
that actually went sideways i wound up
septic
all over my body it particularly hit my
heart
my lungs my kidneys
and what else my heart my lungs my
kidneys and something else but
um at the end of the day i was in a coma
for
three weeks and um it's interesting my
doctors
tell me that yes yes
so when i came out of that coma i had no
idea what happened i thought i got hit
by a car
i had no idea what happened and my
family had to explain to me
that i was very sick and that i nearly
died my doctor said i was
five minutes from death three times
and you know long story short
it was a long recovery but my auntie
clithia came to my recovery bed and she
said girl
do you realize that god sent his warring
and ministering angels
to fight for you and to keep you and
it's not just because
you have it's not just to continue
working at that tech company
you have a greater purpose on your life
and i realized hmm
let me pray about this let me let me
think about this
but at the end of the day i started to
think what bugs me
you know what what do am i not happy
about in this world
and i remember i used to complain and
whine to
recruiters and hr people saying hey
susie with the blonde hair and blue eyes
hire more people that look like me
because i was the only person that
looked like me at most
tech companies that i worked at i didn't
get to see anybody that looked like
myself
on a daily basis and that can tend to
buggy after a while
um so yeah i realized okay stop
whining and complaining let's be the
change that i wanted to see
well literally before we get to just be
sure to get to this change because
you know i i don't get to meet many
people who have gone through
such an extraordinary experience a
horrible experience but extraordinary
nevertheless
of being in a coma for three weeks
waking up give me a little bit of
context as to and pay me a picture of
what's happening there so you wake up
you're you're in the text you're in the
tech world there are things that bother
you and you're going to have all this
passion and ambition to change those
things but what what do you
feel are you confused are you do you
understand what was happening who was
next to paint me that picture because i
think it's fascinating
so i'm really blessed my husband um
when i came out of it the nurses told me
your husband was like a lion at the
front of your bed i'm like my husband
because he's actually usually you know
quite mild-mannered
and um i was very surprised that they
said you know he was really fighting for
me i mean of course i knew he'd fight
for me
but not in the physical way that you
know they had expressed
and um when
he i guess they he asked for permission
to put speakers in the icu
so that they would he could play my
favorite music which is bossa nova
sergio mendes you know and so
when during the coma i could hear the
music
um which is interesting people say can
can you hear anything during a coma yes
you can
at least i did um i remember hearing the
music
i knew i was in a safe place so that
because it's my music nobody else you
know
that i know listens to that music so
when i heard that music i knew that i
was in a safe place
um but coming out of the coma
um it's like coming out of a cloud and
i won't get into like what i thought
happened in there but
it's it's like coming out of a big puffy
cloud
and everything's kind of muted but it's
starting to come
you know start everything's starting to
come awake
and then all you hear people talking and
people are encouraging you
i remember hearing a nurse telling me
come on
you can't die you have a lot to live for
i remember her rubbing my arm
you know i remember her rubbing my arm
um
i could tell the people that came into
the room
um that cared about me i knew that if my
family was there i didn't know who they
were
but i just felt a warm entity that i
knew i was safe and that
person cared about me as opposed to the
brush
of a white jacket you know you hear the
click of a clicking of a the
board uh where your medical stuff is on
and then click it goes back down and
they're gone it's kind of like a white
it was like a
cold breeze that went through right
so um coming out of that
i had no idea what happened what i was
told
is i came out of the surgery and
i was fine i went home doctor said you
can
you know you're up in two weeks and
inevitably i wasn't and
um i passed out in our home
so uh my husband raced me to the
emergency room
and um they told him that my white blood
cell count was off the charts
and to call family and so he
called all of the family i do remember
hearing murmurs of them
talking saying they love me that they're
praying for me but i don't remember
anything after that
supposedly i was in recovery for two
weeks
after they did another surgery and um
i just started to crash i guess i would
they said i was talking to a nurse and
then all of a sudden
um the blue light goes on
and i crashed and um they had to
you know kind of uh revive me and they
called my husband and said we've induced
your wife into a coma so that she
doesn't die
and we don't know what's wrong with her
so
um at that point they my husband had to
call the ceo of the tech company i was
working with
and say yeah i don't think kiwa was
coming back and
um interestingly enough that ceo
happened to know
people on the board of the hospital that
i was at
and my husband he said you know let me
call some people and
um he wound up helping out and my
husband said there was like a guy from
stanford in the room there was like
four you know heads of surgeries and
head of this department of pulmonary
and um after you know a while they
finally figured out what was wrong with
me
and uh proceeded to he said like you
know 10 iv poles showed up in the room
and
they all seemed to know what was going
on now and they knew what to do to
to get me better but he was told it was
still a 50 50 chance
that i would survive right
unbelievable unbelievable so you come
out of this this
crazy experience and you have when you
and you're taking the passion that you
had before
now it sounds like with a deeper purpose
and meaning to
what you can and should be doing with
your time and and
while you would you were doing
extraordinary things in your job and you
still are you chose to con to now devote
another portion of your time to this new
project tell me about girl stem stars
um so as i mentioned i was in my
recovery bed when i came to that you
know enlightenment of okay stop
whining and complaining be the change
that you wanted to see and so
i literally called up i picked up the
phone from my recovery bed
and i called legalzoom and said i want
to start a nonprofit that advances
black girls and girls of color from
underserved communities in stem
and it started to you know roll out from
there
started doing the 501c3 but i found that
i came to
um you know like i was crawling up a
hill but i just got stuck
and um i was talking to one of my
friends who's on the council of
east palo alto and he's like you know
how are you doing and i
burst into tears and he's like what's
going on and i said i've been trying to
do this 501c3 he goes
girl you trying to do a 501c3 while
you're in recovery in bed
he says what are you crazy so he
uh he says you need to speak up and that
was one enlightenment right there
don't carry it all yourself you need
help
everybody every leader needs help
and so he put out the word and found
um a lawyer that was interested in the
work that we were doing and
um i actually crawled out of my recovery
bed to go meet him
and he's like what are you doing here i
thought we were going to be on the phone
i'm like
anybody who wants to help me um with
this project
i want to see you face to face and um at
the end of the day
uh he took the whole project from me
paid for it and
and worked with the irs to do the 501 c
3. so i mean wow i'm a believer so this
is where i say
how god works in my life right and then
um we got
a lot of um recognition
and um participation a lot of volunteers
um i gathered all the girls and we
started doing events
at tech companies so we would take a
group of girls
say a hundred girls over to google and
they would have a whole day you know i
know their parents were grateful that
they get to drop off their kid at 7 30
in the morning
we feed them breakfast we give them
goodie bags t-shirts
you name it and then we're teaching them
we expose them
to amazing mentors like um
black women um astronauts
and uh a vp of of youtube
who is a black woman the girls freaked
out they're like you the boss of youtube
and and she's like yes i am and they're
like oh i want to be like her
boom right automatically have that
child's attention
and that girl wants to be because i
usually ask them who do you want to be
like you know when you grow up they're
like oh i want to be like beyonce
and uh or i want to be a veterinarian so
i can take care of puppies
i want to be a dancer but at the end of
the day when they get to meet
you know uh a woman like this of the
vice president of youtube
which they all relate to um or they get
to meet
a black female rocket scientist from
nasa who has braids just like them
you know i remember she came up and she
said guess how much i make
and they're like i don't know five
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
she goes
i make over two hundred thousand dollars
they're like
what okay i won't be like you you know
automatically
you know after hearing what this woman
does and how much she makes they're
instantly attracted
to um if you will the fame of it
she's a she a new she hero for them a
new stem hero for them
and um you know they're here i like that
yes yes there's lots of instances where
we take a bus load of girls to nasa
and um they get to hang out with the um
black woman
uh resource group there and eat lunch
with them
go sit by sit by their side and and see
what they do on a daily basis
it blows a girl's mind absolutely
wow so talk to me a little bit about
this impact because
first of all i'd like to i'd like to
understand the context of the of the
problem a little bit a little bit bigger
and through that also the the the
opportunity for impact so
you know i'm also coming in from from
outside of the country
and obviously if the one 2020 has
brought up a lot of different
uh adversities one thing that it has
clearly brought up
is the issue of minorities within the
united states and
and the fight for equality and for
diversification everywhere
and obviously what the work that you're
doing with the girl stem stars is
incredible and i'm sure that it's
impacted so many
lives of of young women talk to me a
little bit about this
greater scope so stem girls and
minorities
what what is happening today and and
where are you aiming for
so it's interesting you don't see
girls really interested in math and
science and technology
but when we bring them into um
and when we bring them into a tech
company or at nasa
um but also now that we're because of
covid we're doing virtual learning
uh the fact that they get to see a woman
on the screen ask her questions how did
you get there what did you do
you know that that um mentor will show
pictures of themselves
and the little girl so the girls can
resonate with them like okay
she was like me at one point um this is
where
i believe um all educators need to be
starting
very very young by getting girls
interested in stem
and it's it's super easy to do it in a
fun way
where the girls are learning and they're
excited about it and they see
people they see women that they want to
emulate that they want to be like
and then at this point of the game
you're building um
you know you can see the ambition where
uh you know again
like the the blacks rocket scientists
from nasa you know
they have that if i can see it i can be
it
and this is what we need more of for
minorities um to just be exposed to more
stem
and to and to expose them to more stem
heroes
and it's it's a global thing i
want to glo i want to take girl stem
stars global
um my first uh my first step is to
take it to africa right now what i do is
the videos that you see online of like
the girls visiting google
and and microsoft and such i
share them with my counterparts in
um africa and that enables those girls
out there
to be able to see wow this is what i
have my video guy i'm like
make it like you're walking in and
you're in it like you're in the
experience you know so that the girls in
africa can really feel like
this is what this you know google looks
like this is what nasa looks like this
is what
a black rocket scientist looks like you
know there's there's
there's some stem heroes so what what
has
been the impact of of girl stem stars so
far how many girls have gone through the
program and where
and what you aim it to go to in terms of
you know the scale
right we have touched over a thousand
girls
wow yes yes since inception over a
thousand girls in the bay area
and and further i actually did a stem
camp
uh virtually for girls in malaysia so a
friend of mine was going out there
to um do an educational program and they
said you know would you mind doing girl
stem stars in malaysia i'm like
sure it was amazing to see all the girls
with their you know their headgear
and their little girl stem stars teacher
and they're like hey
um so i definitely now that we're in
this virtual world
the world is my oyster when you when i
you know when you think about it that i
can take
girl stem stars anywhere and that's
that's interesting so you're saying that
you know with with acceleration of
of the virtual collaboration and
interaction that you've decoded
now i mean because you could have done
this before right it could have said
okay
i'm going to focus on primarily virtual
gatherings
rather than you know allocate a lot of
time and resources to going
physically and it actually makes a lot
of sense that that
probably for every field trip that's
organized you could probably organize
five gatherings virtually right for the
same
time of for the same kiwoba time for the
same resources
so it's really fascinating so now you're
planning on taking this global allowing
interaction i'm guessing also from
participants around the world and
what else needs to happen in order to
level the playing field or provide
not not an opportunity for them to study
stem because
i'm guessing that a lot of times they do
but to get their minds
curious about it and to make it socially
acceptable for also
minorities and black girls that you're
targeting to
help them get started in the process
more awareness
needs to be um brought
up into in media because you know kids
are always you know in media
social media and we need more stem
heroes
and we need stem to look cool and fun
right now it's for the nerdy group and
it's not
really you know i mean i show videos of
my husband and i scuba diving
and you know we're kissing underwater
and the girls are like oh that looks
like so much fun
and i'm like do you realize how much
stem is on my back do you realize how
many math and science classes i had to
take before they let me jump off that
boat
and then this is where they're like oh
stem can be fun
too you know i try to teach the girls
that stem is in every aspect of
their lives it's in your phone it's in
you know everything that you do it's in
the computer it's in everything
and um this is where they want to be we
need them to be curious
about every um subject math science
technology
engineering um and also
we need companies to invest you know
in our youth um they keep complaining oh
well
you know the pipeline is dry no it's not
you know you need to start investing in
communities
invest in teaching invest in um
you know also invest in widening their
scope
of uh recruiting so that they're not
just looking at you know
the high profile at hbcus but also city
colleges
and and state colleges you know they
want you know the top four
ivy you know come on that's that's not
who runs the world
all right you know we if if we
want to be able to be successful with
our technology
moving forward we need to include
more minorities otherwise
globally we will not be able to
interact globally our technology will
not
work if we don't invite minorities to
have a
a seat at the table so what we're doing
at girls stem centers is we're starting
them as early as seven years old to 18
years old
and so this is where we're building the
future leaders the future entrepreneurs
the future decision makers
um the future business owners and
this is where we'll see change that's
just wonderful and obviously
you know as this is a non-profit if
anybody happens to to listen to this and
is also passionate about this cause and
would like to contribute i'm sure
that uh that i i can make an
introduction and
send off the contact for girl stem stars
but before we leave kiwoba i have to ask
the most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yes so and thank you for the plug on
donationsgirlstemstars.org you can make
a donation there
um three words about me one i'm faithful
i am a believer and i'm truly grateful
that
god has put this calling for girl stem
stars on my life and it's
amazing it changed my life it changes
the life of every person who ever comes
and volunteers with these girls they're
like oh my gosh
i didn't realize it was so easy to just
come
and roll up my sleeves meet these girls
and then the at the end of an eight-hour
day or if it's just a couple of hours on
a virtual
you know the girls are so fun and they
see the little light bulbs going off in
the girls minds
they're like so moved going i want to do
that again so we're not just touching
the girls but we're also touching you
know
employees at different companies we're
touching executives
um and so this is it's a great calling
and it's it needs to happen right now
right now this is a very rich
environment for
um the world to be able to start
making a difference on their own so like
here is this was my situation where
i don't see black people on a daily
basis in silicon valley
but what is important to somebody else
you know what what what makes you tick
what's important to you or what bugs you
right i'm asking you well for me it's
the dissemination of information
there's so many people like you that are
so influential and have so many
incredible experiences that
without a medium to disseminate this
information
the majority of the population will not
be able to hear it and especially the
stories that i try to cover here these
are not
tech crunch or crunch based stories
these are more about the journeys and
the reason
the passion that you starting girl stem
stars and this sort of epiphany that you
had and this and
this passion that you've acquired over
the years and the trigger from that coma
that's exactly the things that i like
that i'd like to share right so you're
you're already walking out
your your and that's my next word is
passion you're really work
working out walking out your passion um
i when i've
been on stage before as a motivational
speaker you know i asked some of the
people in the front row you know so
you know what what are you interested in
you know what what bugs you
and one woman is like i love the beach
i'm like well get your friends together
and go clean it up
she's like oh my gosh it's that easy i'm
like yes find a purpose in your life
other than just
the typical job that you do on a daily
basis it's as simple as
okay the next woman okay what are you
interested in well i love animals i love
dogs
well then go take care of some dogs you
know
go to a shelter bring your friends get a
facebook group going do something
and you know you'll feel better as a
human being
than just crunching at your daily job
when you
have you have a purpose right
and it's so easy just think about you
know what
am i interested in what or what i don't
like in this world
and then be the change you want to see
and get out there grab your friends and
do it
it's that simple and i don't think you
know everybody needs a god epiphany and
have to nearly die to be
able to come to where i've gotten to you
know
i'm telling people you can skip all that
i'm just telling you it's this easy
right it's this easy and then um
my next one is driven
you know i'm faithful i'm passionate and
i'm driven
as you that definitely you know of
trying to
start a non-profit from my recovery bed
100 yes very hundred percent
kiwoba thank you very much for the time
and for the inspiration this was just a
eye-opening and just wonderful thank you
very very much yes it's been an
honor to be here thank you so much for
um
showcasing girl stem stars today and the
work that we're doing
god bless you i appreciate it
you